edouard philippe l'annoncé les marchés
ouverts ne sont plus autorisés sauf en
cas de dérogation
conséquence certains commerçants se
retrouvent avec leurs marchandises sur
les bras ils doivent recourir au système
d reportage estelle farge et nicolas
coupé elisabeth est indépendante depuis
12 ans elle vend des fruits et légumes
six jours sur sept sur les marchés d'île
de france c'est dans ce camion d'où
qu'elles stockent sa marchandise alors
on a de la mâche ou du gros collier on
facture de au moins 3000 euros 3000
euros de marchandises qu'elle ne peut
découler car les marchés alimentaires
ouverts sont dorénavant interdits
pendant la période de confinement pour
elisabeth c'est la catastrophe
moi je perds des sous et je paye ma
marchandise que je peux pas revendre les
parts du 3000 euros c'est juste un oui
c'est pas grand chose mais si pour une
petite pme comme moi je suis tout seul
oui oui c'est très serré c'est assez
lourd c'est très lourd c'est surtout
qu'on l'avait déjà a subi les
manifestations les gilet jaune et voilà
ça fait plus d'un an qu'on est vraiment
sur la sellette
elle regrette que le gouvernement ne
leur est pas laisser de délai pour se
préparer
on a été prévenu en dernière minute
enfin à 20h30 alors qu'on commence nous
à 5 heures du matin donc automatiquement
les camions sont déjà chargées sont déjà
pas les commandes sont déjà prêts passés
nous on aurait été prévenu à l'avancé on
n'aura pas fait nos achats y aurait
prévu à l'avance vaut mieux ne pas
gagner que de perdre alors pour
elisabeth c'est le système d une amie de
sa fille lui a commandé 30 euros de
fruits et légumes
elle va lui faire un panier pour tenter
comme elle le dit de sauver les meubles
on a le droit nous faire des livraisons
donc je vais préparer le truc pas la
commande la personne et puis je vais
aller lui ramener qui n'est pas très
loin de la maison
donc voilà la pommes poires bananes ya
pas dead on nous met de but en blanc
qu'il faut faire comme ci comme ça comme
ci comme ça et pas au détriment de
cendres de se rendre compte si oui ou
non on va s'en sortir ils en ont rien à
faire mais alors strictement rien à
faire seuls quelques marchés pourront
subsister en cette période de
confinement mais uniquement lorsque ce
dernier est le seul moyen d'avoir accès
à des produits frais